bill how are you as I sit at the base of
Camelback Mountain and all the red rocks
and the gleaming golden light of day
just coming from the east and the
verdant green of this desert I have
never seen the Sonoran Desert this green
with the record rains that we had this
fault is some winter excuse me in the
southwest of the United States here the
greatest part of the greatest planet in
our universe here and it was so
fantastic because underneath that
Saguaro tree just so powerful so
magnificent right next to the Palo Verde
bloom Gold resplendent yellow the red
tips of the Ocotillo the Choi is the
aloes all right there and then the
rattlesnakes slithering around my feet
the lizards the iguanas and then I
looked up and against the Sun there were
the circling pterodactyls
and I knew I knew that this was my
moment this was my time my opportunity
as I looked across the desert and there
was that big white mushroom of the where
the games will be played tonight Dan and
it was just so perfect the harmonic
convergence was in incredible alignment
and I'm ready I'm ready to make the
positive difference and here as we've
had this chance the chance to change the
history of the world one more day I want
to pay specific honor attributed and
acknowledgement to our host here Arizona
State University Michael crow the
president learn his story this is the
future his new athletic director ray
Anderson a Stanford and NFL man
and then Bobby Hurley the future of the
conference of Champions and it's all
going to play out tonight in the big
white mushroom there with Gonzaga and
North Carolina it's going to be
fantastic
Doug tomorrow the greatest si D and the
history of the known world has put it
all together for us and tonight when
they put that ball up and the two hands
go ever higher to determine the fate of
Western civilization one more night I am
going to be the
it's going to be fantastic I'll be with
Jim Gray I'll be with Howard and Rob
Kevin Kugler all the guys from Westwood
One and I am indeed the luckiest guy in
the world because I get to start my day
with my first conversation that is not
one way with my best friend Dan Patrick
how are you today sir
great bills best-selling memoir back
from the dead just came out in paperback
he'll be doing the Westwood one called
the radio call tonight Westwood one
radio it was such an interesting
experience because at one end it was
really tough and the business part with
simon and schuster always taught there
that's not my thing but the personal
relationships Jonathan Karp Julia
Prosser Stephen Bedford and then all the
people who I got to meet on the book
tour and all the stories and what's the
way it is when I go back to Oregon and
I'm so sad what happened with the Oregon
Ducks over the weekend I mean they had a
chance and they couldn't make one shot
they couldn't get lung be bound they
couldn't make one defensive stand but
when I go back to Oregon and it was such
a special time and I'm not even sure if
you're old enough Dan to have been alive
at those moments it was 40 40 years ago
43 years ago when I first got there but
I run into people and then look at me
with these days kaleidoscope eyes and
they point right in my chest and in the
softest but most passionate and earnest
tones they say bill I was there I was
there and it was so spectacular so fun
such a great team and we were able to
capture that and as I went out on this
book tour for Simon & Schuster I got to
meet so many more people and the impact
man and be the comments I'm the luckiest
guy in the world man because people they
treat me better than I deserve
but Bill you know what bothered me when
you guys won the title in Portland
somebody stole your bike when you guys
went to the parade I was always bummed
out about that did you ever get you got
my bike back though I got my bike back
that's how cool being on the Blazers
being on the Bruins being on the Celtics
that was being I was like being on the
Grateful Dead
to her and where everybody was happy it
was joyous it was fun and it was so
positive and always looking forward to
it so when I got up on stage
age and they finally gave me the
microphone and I said will somebody
please give me my bike back and then I
poured the beer over me Oh [ __ ] and
then I did get my bike back took a
couple days but I got it back and our
oldest son Adam he wrote he wrote it for
years and I don't know what happened to
that bike I'm sure it's out there still
being ridden it was fantastic would you
be I know that you weren't eligible to
play your freshman year and grant CLA
but usually won the championship built
my freshman year
yeah that's with Steve Patterson and my
fitnah wicks Sidney wicks the greatest
college basketball forward that I've
ever seen and he was so much better than
everybody else he was a three-time
champion one of only 14 players to ever
do that 12 of them are still alive and
Sidney was the main guy for the second
and third years Korean was the lead guy
on the first year clearly and Curtis
Rowe was on that team but but right
would you have been one and done today
no I love UCLA I did it that was such a
fantastic and that was my dream I mean
it was 52 years ago in 1965 and I was 12
years old that I first saw a basketball
on television it was a Michigan UCLA
game played in the Portland a boyo
Coliseum and we didn't have a TV growing
up but I got to watch this game at a
neighbor's house and it completely
changed my life because I looked at
these little skinny scrawny guys for
Johnny wouldn't like Gail Goodrich and
Keith Derrick's and it ready gosh and
everybody had one yeah right right but
it was a game of skill it was the aim of
Speedos game a quickness fundamentals
physical fitness and that's it I said
that day then that's what I want to do
with the rest of my life and now my
dreams change all the time you got you
got to read Phil Knight shoo dog I mean
so many life lessons in that book
including on page 2 the plan changes
every day
so after my NCAA dream then it was on to
the NBA but in my life damn athletics
academics has always been the easiest
part of my life my challenges have been
orthopedic health and my or if
experiment learning how to speak is my
greatest accomplishment and your worst
nightmare is and I'm sorry for always
loading
show your career and also would be bill
would you sent the record straight right
you're not 611 I am six oh no you're not
no the last time I was measured I was
nineteen I walked across the room as
Coach wooden and ducky Draper doing all
the measurements at the first day of
practice right there and he was going
okay Jamal Wilkes up against the wall
667 Greg Lee 65 Larry farmer Larry
Hollyfield 66 65 and then I come walking
across room where this my turn as I get
halfway across the room John Wooden
looks at me and he says you're 611 yeah
I guess I was the last time I was
measured I was 19 but it's not how big
you are how big you play no you're seven
- you have to be seven - every time I
see it I'm taller than six every time I
think I'm taller than 611 I go and I
stand next to Kareem and in ten days
we'll be celebrating his 70th birthday
party at Staples Center and Lori and I
will get to be there in Luke's last game
of the years the coach and but every
time I think I'm taller than six or
seven I go stand next to Kareem and I'm
three inches shorter than him or I go
stand next to gel me and I'm a foot and
a half shorter than you helming so but
but my whole deal was always about
trying to beat the big guys because I
was not the tallest I was not the
strongest I was not the fastest I could
not the highest jumper but the dream of
beating the big guys and that's when you
know you're a player and when you go up
against somebody who's got more athletic
skills more size and more strength and
you can still get the job done and
that's going to be the challenge for
Gonzaga tonight because these teams are
basically the same dominant skilled deep
physical powerful and well schooled when
the fundamentals by their great coaches
front lines and then you got similar
perimeter guys but the question is going
to be is because you're going to come
down to as the team's did on Saturday
night who can play offense offense wins
championships who can create shots and
there's beautiful players out there I
love watching Joel berry play I love to
watch it Justin Jackson play I love
watching a Williams draws play and Zac
cones are now ski is a very interesting
player so it's going to be super fun but
at
marry end of the day who can create
shots that was Kareem who was the
greatest player I ever played against
that was Larry who was the best player I
ever played with that was Michael Jordan
that was Magic Johnson that was will
that was Oscar that was my all-time
favorite player Bill Russell cuz even
though he's thought of known as a
defensive player he started the offense
he made the first play to create the
initial advantage and then the rest of
the guys where there was kuzey Sharman
Casey Sam Havlicek uh all the different
guys Don Nelson Don Cheney and just in
this incredible legacy of Celtic
greatness which is with Danny Ainge at
the helm at Stephenson now they'll
Isaiah Thomas they're coming back and I
think they're going to play for first
place this Wednesday night I don't know
I've just been so busy here at this
fantastic for this fine night this Final
Four scuse me I'm all fired up there's
alright then the book is back from the
dead out in paperback bill part of the
broadcast for tonight's national title
game on Westwood one radio we hope to
have you in studio bill one of these
days that would be great to reminisce
with you again I much prefer to be face
to face with you although then I'm sure
you're thinking I hope I never see this
guy thanks for having me thank you was a
game the road to the Final Four end to
your thank you Michael crow thank you
Arizona State thank you Doug camera land
Thank You sunshine the Sonora Desert the
Saguaro is that Aerodactyl the Palo
Verde trees fee ocotillo the red tips I
am on fire and I'm ready to go put me in
coach I'm ready to play today look at me
I can be the guy in middle John Fogerty
yeah let's play ball
he's building a Hall of Fame the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience